bitcoin is a new digital currency and
that it's perhaps the best form of money
we have ever seen it's important because
most of us don't understand money very
well and perhaps the the concept that is
harder for us to understand our money is
that money isn't has always been a
ledger people often ask what is money
backed with and the truth is money is
not backed with anything it has never
been back with anything the euro is not
back with anything in particular and
neither is any other currency in the
world and gold for example for that
matter is not back with anything either
some people think that gold has value
because we use it for jewelry but it's
other way it's actually the other way
around
Gold is valuable because it's very
scarce and because it's very scarce it
has been the best ledger we found 5000
years in Bitcoin we have something that
is as good a ledger as as gold meaning
there it's it's incredibly scarce there
will never be more than 21 million
bitcoins it's even more scarce than gold
but in history we have had this
trade-off between things that have been
very very good store of value like gold
for example and things that have been
good for payment like like the
portuguese school or the US dollar or
american airline miles or facebook
credit those things are better for
payment but they're not so good as a
store of value historically and the
things are a good for a store of value
like gold are not good for payment in
bitcoin we have something for the first
time there is incredibly superior than
anything we have seen before
as a store of value and also as a form
of payment it's hard to have a rigorous
discussion about bitcoin without
understanding money and the best way to
understand money is to understand the
history of money and tripoli just agree
that there's no drive much less a
civilization that ever base its commerce
on barter and there's no evidence barter
never happened and that's
counterintuitive to most of us because
we are taught in school that we first
partner and then we made money because
barter was too complicated
well better never happened and that's
one of the key sort of myths about money
so then you would ask the anthropologist
like ok so how do we do commerce before
before my
if there was no barter and there was no
commerce no there was plenty of Commerce
and the way that commerce would happen
is that let's say that someone in our
tribe had killed a big Buffalo and I
would go up to a person and say hey can
I have a little bit of meat and that
person would say no or yes
once here's your meat and then you would
go up to a person and say hey can I have
a little bit of meat and that person
said yes here's your meat and basically
we all had to keep track in our heads of
what we owed other people are what are
people oh this and then someone would
come to me and say hey once this kind of
have a little bit of firewood and I
would say sure here's your firewood and
I have to remember that I owe that
person a little bit that this person
owes me a little and we all went around
about our business with these Ledger's
in our minds of who owes us what who
what do we owe Tom very subjective
system often these debts didn't clear or
clearly ways that were not satisfactory
to both parties until about 25,000 years
ago someone very very intelligent came
up with a new technology that really
took off which came to me and said I
kind of have a little bit of firewood
and I said sure here's your firewood and
this person said this time we're going
to try something different
here are some beads for you and I said I
don't want beads I don't care for it
I'll need beads and said it's not about
that we're going to use beads as the
objective ledger of our tribe instead of
each of us having to remember what we
rode the beads are going to keep track
for us an objective ledger to keep track
of debt and it was such a successful
technology that it took off and in a
couple thousand years it became
impossible to find a tribe or
civilization that didn't have some form
of objective ledger in some cases it was
one pawn shells in our places it was
salt in our bases rocks or beads but
this form of keeping track of debt with
an objective ledger took off and
anthropologists go as far as saying that
if you describe a tribes environment in
detail they can predict what's going to
merge us as an objective ledger as money
because it's always something that has
six qualities the most important of
which is that it be scarce and it makes
sense because if it's not scarce we can
create you know if we were to use tree
leaves for example we could create
debts owed to us out of thin air
that wouldn't be good that wouldn't be a
good ledger but also has to be durable
if it's something that decades or
corrodes it doesn't store the
information well it has to be divisible
it has to be transportable recognizable
and fungible and this system really
worked until about 5000 years ago when
trade we can began to extend a lot
geographically and we began to trade
with other tribes and different tribes
were using different Ledger's so they
couldn't trade with each other and what
happened then about 5000 years ago
is that gold emerged as the first
universal ledger to keep keep track of
debt and it was gold because it was
universally scarce that was the most
important consideration but also it was
very very durable fairly divisible
transportable recognizable and fungible
and that's why for five thousand years
gold has been the best store of value
we've I've ever seen it's incredible
that today if you need to leave five
thousand dollars for someone for your
daughter not not your daughter or your
granddaughter but some great-great
great-great great-great-great-great
granddaughter of yours forty generations
from now nine hundred years from now we
don't know how to do that if you leave
it in just dollars it's not going to be
worth very much we know of no security
that will last that long the only thing
that we know can carry value for that
long is you need to be by five thousand
dollars worth of gold lock it in a vault
and give the key to that person nine
hundred years from now it's incredible
and in the 21st century this is the best
answer we have this is why a bitcoin is
so relevant because it's the first time
in five thousand years that we have
something that is incredibly superior to
gold in each one of these six
characteristics it's much more scarce
than gold there will never be more than
21 million bitcoins it's more divisible
than gold and each Bitcoin is composed
of a million pieces called satoshis it's
much more durable divisible
transportable you know I can have a
Skype call from here New York to someone
in Jakarta and I can see them in real
time and I can hear them and they can
see me and they can hear me incredible
the technological accomplishment of that
but if after hanging up I want to send
them one sent to Jakarta even though I
have the cent in my pocket and you will
be trivial if they were here I we don't
know how to do that it's not possible in
the 21st century to send to send a
central jakarta one because you will
more than 50 cents to send it to because
you will take a week to get there and
three because just there are no systems
to do about Bitcoin fixes that makes it
trivial easy to send that sent to
Jakarta or a million dollars to Jakarta
you can attach a Bitcoin to an SMS
message or an email and send it for free
and in real time across the world and
it's incredibly easy to verify the
second you get a Bitcoin you know that
it's a good Bitcoin so has all of the
qualities of a great ledger made in
digital and because of that is probably
the best form of money we've ever seen